by now I've interviewed more than 300
leaders and I always just listen for
patterns and themes that come up during
the course of the interviews and I
started hearing a lot of great insights
about culture and I heard this one
expression from one of the CEOs where he
said we want to be the largest small
company in our space and I was really
intrigued by that what does that mean
how do you do that obviously largest in
terms of size smallest in terms of just
that startup culture feel and that just
got me thinking about culture and and
what it means and the thing about
culture is that it's such an amorphous
word I mean if you know got ten people
in front of a whiteboard and said what
is culture you could put a hundred
things on it and they would all be true
because it is such a fuzzy concept so
the more I thought about the more I
tried to frame the question in the right
way about culture and I really framed it
this way which is what are the biggest
drivers of culture the things that if
done well have an outsize positive
impact and if done badly or not at all
have an outsize negative impact and that
was really the question that framed the
book and I just went through you know
millions of words of transcripts looking
for the insights that helped answer that
question in terms of why now for this
book I really think that culture is
increasingly the X Factor that's going
to separate companies because business
is just moving so fast there's so much
disruption in so many industries and you
can have two companies with a similar
strategy similar backing and the one
that's gonna win is the one with the
better culture a lot of people don't
focus on culture though because it is so
amorphous people tend to focus on
strategy they tend to focus on results
because you can put the results in a
spreadsheet but culture is really the
the X Factor that's going to drive the
results and I've heard that from a lot
of really smart CEOs I wrote the book as
a as really a playbook
because CEOs just have so many things on
their plates they could do literally a
hundred different things on any
different day they're responsible for
everything and kind of
nothing at the same time and because
culture is so amorphous it can be hard
for them to figure out well is this a
good use of my time so that's why I
really tried to frame it around the the
question what are the biggest drivers so
that if they're really focused on these
things that they would see an impact
even if it's not super tangible but just
to know based on the experience of a
hundreds of other CEOs that this had an
impact on their company if you're a
start-up CEO you really have to be
thoughtful about culture because you're
gonna have culture one way or another
it's gonna happen on its own and every
company's culture is different it's
really the sum total of kind of the DNA
of the people in your company and the
metaphor that I like to use about
culture is that it's sort of like
cholesterol in any organization you're
gonna have good and bad culture and just
like with cholesterol you're gonna have
good and bad cholesterol the trick is to
focus on the things that are really
going to boost the good aspects of the
culture and make sure that the things
that are going to hurt your culture
don't creep into your company and I've
heard a lot of really compelling stories
about that I interviewed Tony Hsieh the
CEO of Zappos now with his first company
where as a co-founder he reached a point
where he didn't even want to go to work
in the morning he told this story about
how he used to just keep hitting the
snooze button because he didn't want to
go into work at the company that he
founded and that was pretty remarkable
and that's one of the reasons why he
focused so much on culture when he went
to Zappos because he just learned that
you have to be deliberate about it and
there are all sorts of romantic notions
about a startup culture and many of them
are true that sense of we're all in it
together that there's an impact
you know everybody's kind of picking up
an oar and rowing together
not all startup cultures are great and
we shouldn't think that they are there
can be a lot of chaos and if leadership
isn't focused on culture then then
you're gonna get the kind of problems
that Tony Hsieh had but it is important
to try and hold on to that startup spark
because what that really means is that
sense that people are committed to
mission it's not just work for them
they're not just punching a clock and to
me one of the biggest drivers of that
one of the most effective tools for
creating that sense is what I call a
simple plan I think it's a leaders job
to stand up in front of their employees
and effectively say this is where we're
going and this is how we're going to get
there the reason that's so important is
that people need to understand how the
work they are doing is going to
contribute to those broader goals and
there really can't be more than three
because all the brain science shows that
most people can't remember more than
three things day to day anyways so you
have to pick the right measures and if
you do that then you will really tap
into people's desire to contribute to
something because I really think as
human beings were wired that way we want
to contribute to the team we want to
help but it's a leaders job to say this
is the scoreboard and it's very clear
and it's very simple and then you get
that benefit of people saying I
understand now how the work I'm doing
will help us reach those goals because
if you don't do that that's when you get
silo behavior whether it's people
operating in their department or
division essentially pursuing their own
goals but that can also play out at an
individual level people are just doing
their own thing and that's when you get
all the politics and turf eNOS and silos
can be really dangerous and one CEO said
to me silos are what toppled the
greatest companies and even a company
like Microsoft by its own admission in
the summer of 2013 said that you know
they have a problem with their
organization they have to look at the
organization chart to create much more
of a one Microsoft culture and I think
as companies get bigger they really have
to contend with that
you